Good evening.
Are there any questions from
anything that we discussed in
the past?
He just key enable the MIC for
everyone.
OK.
Then we will continue from where
we left in the last class.
I hope.
No, E no.
The concept of decision tree is
pretty clear and to construct a
decision tree we use heuristics,
and that heuristic can be either
a Gini index or entropy party
classification error.
So in either case, our intention
is to is to find pure end nodes
by dividing the training data
based on various attributes.
We keep trying with various
attributes.
OK, Mr Rajesh, there were a
couple of questions on canvas.
Based on the quiz prediction.
OK.
Yes, Mr Rajesh.
Yeah, we can talk.
We can talk.
I had asked.
See, The thing is that I wanted
there was one.
Ohh participant Mr Kapil Garg,
who has raised the question and
he is not present.
But if it is a question for
everyone, yeah, sure, I can
answer that.
OK, so let's.
Uh, can somebody tell me what is
the?
What is the thing that is really
requires clarification?
OK.
OK, Mr Rajesh, I'm sure.
See.
See first thing is that there
are conventions which we need to
follow.
So the point is that the what
association discovers is based
on the data that is present, so
it is going to create an
association rule based on the
data it is studied.
So.
So the point is that is it going
to be used for some predictive
purposes in the future?
It is possible.
It is possible it can be used,
but then association itself is
ends.
The task ends with the finding
the rules, so all we are saying
is that it is descriptive and
that is what people agree to
describe it as.
So does that clarify?
So it doesn't mean that in the
future you cannot use it for
some thing like inventory
management, you want to predict
inventory, maybe you can use it.
But then association task is
only finding the rules based on
the past data and the experts
called it decision descriptive.
So let's go with it and any
issue I think that is what we
discussed in the class in the
first session, what the
association is.
Uh.
A descriptive so so, but then
someone is still has a doubt
saying that OK association.
I think I myself may have
mentioned that association can
Yeah.
also be used, yes.
OK.
Would you?
Yes, somebody is asking your
question.
Please go ahead.
Is someone asking a question or
or or OK it was in noise coming
from somebody's mic.
OK.
OK. OK.
Thank you, Mr Rajesh.
Good that you reminded it.
So if somebody is having a doubt
but still not able to somehow
not bringing out.
Yeah, it helps.
So the idea is that we have to
go with sit and conventions in
everything.
For example, let's go into the
our school days, our school days
when we were studying and you
can see lots of motion.
Everybody says this is the first
line.
This is second law.
This is third law, but you
cannot say that the third law is
looking very basic.
So I want to put it as a first
level.
In that case you will have
difficulty communicating with
anybody else, right?
So in any case that there is a
reason why association is called
as a descriptive because it is
giving you a, it is.
The rules are found only by
studying the the data and
there's sociation mining is done
once you find the rules so so
that is the reason.
OK, Mr Bishop Sukhada is ideas.
Assignment will be given after
mid semester.
OK.
And so we'll proceed further.
I hope things are clear.
So we had discussed about the.
So let me put them in writing.
Answer One question related to
the quiz if that's fine.
Yes, yes, yes.
So on the cheese quest, Sir, on
that key square, if the key
square is larger, it means that
attributes are not related,
right?
K Square test, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, right.
Yeah.
Right.
If it is lower, less than that,
yes, yes.
So, Mr Basavaraju right?
Yeah.
So So what is the question?
Yes, Sir.
So you guys square value is
between 2 nominal attributes is
larger means those attributes
are not related, right Sir?
No, no, they are related.
So Ayer the value means it
related and lower value means it
not related.
Lower is essentially close to 0
is that there is no relation.
OK.
Yes, zero is no relation.
Yes, OK.
OK, Miss Pratima has a question.
Smoothing aggregation,
normalization.
Not part of the data
transformation.
OK, Miss Pratima, what do you
think is the answer?
We are talking about data
transformation.
Miss PRITIBALA, you.
I think you can speak your
microphone is ohh smoothing, but
smoothing is doing
transformation right.
It is doing some approximations
of the values.
If you are getting the values
which are close.
Ah yes, Mr Regenera says it is a
aggregation, right.
Aggregation is a reasonable
because The thing is that the
aggregate the try it is not
really doing a transformation of
the data right when suppose that
you have you have the support.
Yeah, I suppose.
What?
What can that be?
Suppose that there is a some
scoring goals related some
football, football related data
set and there is a team which is
scoring some goals in all the
matches and somehow you also
wanted to find which team has
scored the maximum goals.
So then you are not transforming
the data right?
You are only adding Miss
Pratima.
Are you there or you're not?
There you asked and then you
became quite yeah.
Are you fine?
OK, OK alright.
So anyone else remembering
something that we can quickly
take?
OK.
Thank you.
OK.
So we talked about
classification.
We looked at three heuristics.
To be we we looked at a greedy
approach to build the tree.
Oh yeah.
Big decision trees.
And then there are three
heuristics which are Jenny.
Entropy and error.
I hope uh, it's so far so good.
OK, so so now now I'm hoping
that.
So.
So with that, So what we have
seen is that I we mentioned
about the gain ratio, there are
some algorithms that are there
in the there in the library.
So you can you build the the
entry using the Python.
There are, uh, cyclic has the
has the function and it is
possible that there are more
libraries which have got
differently and each person will
be writing the program in their
own way, maybe with some
variations and and we have seen
that there is one way which the
an algorithm.
I think it is.
I don't remember the algorithm
named.
The tree is used for the C 4.5
which is using easy.
The gain ratio gain ratio is
used by C 4.5 and what it does
is that it is getting the gain
in the entropy.
OK, so you get the.
Compute.
Gain in entropy.
For all attributes.
And then divide by this split
information.
So what we do is that we divide
the gain by split information
for the attribute so that the
attribute which creates 20
branches or 60 branches even
though it is creating pure data
sets.
We do not want to give it the
higher weight is we want to give
higher weight is too the
attributes which do minimum
splits.
But at the same time, they're
going to give you a significant
improvement in the purity.
OK, so that was the concept that
we last discussed in the class.
So that goes beyond these
heuristics.
So.
So the point is, these are the
simple level heuristics, Gini
entropy error, and then you can
complicate them and thereby you
can get a better, more simple,
more explainable decision.
OK, so now let us look at what
is the way in which we can
refine the decision tree
further.
So we want to look at are Mr
Amit Chaudhary, are you trying
to say something?
Uh.
Because I'm or you may want to
mute yourself because it shows
that you are trying to speak.
OK.
Yes, Mr Kapil Gargi, you are
there.
OK, you're there in the class,
so I hope we discussed about
Yeah.
your doubt before you joined.
Is there anything that uh, you
want you want to ask?
No, said.
I'm good.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Alright. OK.
So those who are not speaking,
please mute your mic so that I
don't get a confusion that
somebody's trying to say
something and uh, OK.
OK, so so The thing is that we
worked we we looked at a toy
data set, right, we looked at.
That is small data set.
And it was possible for us to
build all pure leaves.
All the leaves were pure because
when we worked with the taxi
wage and dataset, which is
small, we got all the leaves.
But then but then it is possible
that you may get a data set
which has got 1,000,000 records
and then you start dividing and
then even after going 10
branches down the tree 10 levels
down from the root, you may
still not get pure leaves.
So at that point you think you
have to think in terms of an
early termination because these
are all good things.
So if you get a pure your note.
There's just the for me.
And impossible situation when
all attributes are the same
value, then it is impossible
situation.
So those are the two extreme
things, but then even otherwise,
Yep.
when you got a very large data
set, you will.
You're never going to get either
of the situation, so you need to
think of early termination.
So in that context, let's look
at some of the issues.
So when we build a classifier.
And in our case, the example is
a decision tree and it holds for
any many other classifiers that
you may learn in this course or
in the other courses.
So the problem is that you may
have a classifier that is either
No.
doing an underfitting.
So we are saying that we will
only use one attribute and get
some level of accuracy and then
we stop there.
So in the tax dataset, what we
said is let's say we decide
that.
So I will use only one attribute
which is income.
And then greater than 95K, and
I'm saying that if it is greater
OK.
than this, this is known and
This is why.
So this is a very simple and
very highly interpretable a
decision tree, but the question
is that this is both of them are
impure.
So is this.
This is called underfitting, so
we are building something very
simple and so the accuracy will
be low and it will have a very
superior interpretability and
overfitting.
Is that suppose you got a data
set which is running into
hundreds of thousands of data
and then you said that no, I
want pure leaves.
All the all the pure leaves.
And then you are willing to go
all the way up to the 100th
level in the dish entry, and
then you're going to get purely.
But the problem is that in such
cases the date the classified
tends to be more complex than
the real world events.
So in that case we are going to
get a zero training error
because the with the training
data it is giving pure leaves.
That is, each leaf node is
representing a pure class, but
then once we start testing with
test data, so we will have a
problem.
So if we have two simple.
So in that case it has got a
significant error, so this is
representing the error.
I hope you're able to read this
and then this is the.
This is the complexity of the
tree number of nodes.
That is what we are putting it
so when it has very few nodes it
is very simple but then the
error will be high and then
suppose that you ended up with
very complex.
Suppose 100 nodes.
OK, so it is too complex.
With two complex what is
happening?
We are getting nearly zero
training error.
The training error the blue line
is representing the training
error that is.
Check with the training data and
then how it is performing, but
then with the test data it is
giving more and more errors so
you can see that with
underfitting the both training
and test errors are very high.
But once we do, the overfitting
training error becomes very very
small and may even go to 0.
But the test error is going to
be large.
So so now the challenge is that
challenge is that we don't want
to go for underfitting.
Let us avoid that.
So that so can you give example
of that the training error and
the test error? How?
That one.
OK, OK.
So now let us go to the data
set.
This data set OK, so let us
still stick with this data set
because I'll I'll otherwise have
a A so it becomes.
OK, so now let us say we build a
decision tree.
You.
Uh.
Income. Great.
Sorry to interrupt, sorry.
And then 95K.
Yes, somebody has a question
greater than 95K.
He's mute.
Mute.
Yes, Sir.
I'm just so just I'm requesting.
Can you please mute Amit
Chaudhary?
He's uh.
He's forget to mute the mic mic
and.
OK.
OK, just let me let me check,
dear, let me finish this income
greater than 95K.
So how many are there, 1234?
OK, 4 tuples, 4 tuples and 1234.
OK, so this is not good.
This is not good, so I'll go for
something.
Some of that number.
OK.
I'll go for 85K, OK.
85 came.
No.
85 K OK, 85K is, so maybe let me
make it 84 K OK 84K greater than
84K.
How many I've.
I've got 1234567 OK seven tuples
on this side greater than uh.
OK so.
So true.
Falls.
So I have 7 tuples here and
three tuples here.
OK.
Greater than 84K and three
tuples are 70K60K and 75K.
OK, so so now now the problem is
OK.
Let's.
So now let us look at the
dataset so so this decision tree
is very simple, right?
But now look at this.
The other.
Uh Ford knows and two yeses and
here 1S and three nodes.
So so we can see that the the
trees.
Simple, but then it is not
helping us to solve the problem.
You guys.
So does that underfitting help?
So if we have more bigger tree,
we can we'll be able to solve
Thank you.
the problem.
Is that clear?
Or somebody still has it out.
Let's talk you can.
Look at some.
I think am I allowed to mute
which?
You know.
But we work.
I don't know.
It is not.
It is not showing.
I have to go and check find the
person.
Some mute all and then unmute.
So ohh.
OK.
I didn't do that work.
OK.
OK, before I before I do that,
the underfitting overfitting
there is one person with a
problem is that clear or or me
are we?
Yeah.
Who asked that question about
Underfitting and overfitting
explanation.
Somebody asked for it, right?
And OK, I I'm not able to.
Yeah.
Yes miss.
I asked about.
Yeah.
I asked about the test data and
ohh A oh can you go back to that
one?
I was confused with that one
that slide please.
OK, so suppose that we we
created this type of tree.
It is very simple, right?
Missouri, you agree it is
simple, right?
Yes, yes, yes.
It is simple, but do you think
that it is going to help the
income tax authorities
sufficiently?
No, no, no, because we are not
getting the clear cut indication
Yes. See.
with whatever the dividing
technique we have.
Yeah.
See and also and also we need to
think that there are three
attributes which seem to be
helpful.
But we are using only one
attribute but in real problem
there may be 20 attributes which
are useful and we are using only
two or three attributes.
So in that case it is unlikely
that this is going to help.
So this is underfitting.
OK, Sir. OK.
So overfitting is that we are
trying to use everything.
In this case the overfitting may
not be because there are only
three attributes.
You will say that still it is
simple, but then you may have a
data set with 10 attributes or
100 attributes and you create a
very complex decision tree and
with using all 100 attributes
then that becomes overfitting.
So that overfitting is that in
such cases it is noticed that
with training error training
data we may get 100 zero percent
Yeah, more than just now
correctly.
error 100% accuracy.
But with the test data, they
generally end up with higher
error.
Angola.
OK, I'm going to.
Umm.
I'm going to.
OK, I'm what I'm doing and.
Gale, though.
Amit, can you mute yourself?
OK, I'm going to disable the mic
for.
OK, let only for Amit Chaudhary
maybe helps.
OK, so now now let us look at
the the problem.
Over Anand mentioned just said.
So what we are saying is that
with yes.
But it is still not muted, so I
think.
I muted only for or person who
who could not mute himself.
Ohh and.
Are you still hearing some?
There's more people.
So should I mute every game?
It mute all of us there because
more and more people are here,
OK.
yeah.
Yeah.
OK.
OK, fine, I'll do that.
So I'll unmute after 10 minutes
and then then we can discuss.
So in such cases, when we have a
very complex decision tree with
hundred nodes, so in that case
the test data, it is not going
to do well because we try to
overfit with the training data.
So, but then we have to know
that training data, everything
in the training data cannot be
treated like a Bible.
So we need to stop at some place
and may have to accept a little
bit of error and then create a
tree which and then which a
domain expert can understand or
interpret.
Because if we keep going on
building a very, very complex
tree, then the test error will
be large.
So how to avoid the
overshooting?
So we can do it in two ways.
One is that we can do a pre
pruning.
Pre pruning is that we stop
early, so stop the algorithm
before it becomes so.
When so that can be.
This is a general situation, so
this is we already talked about
all the same class, then and
then the same attribute.
This is impossible to
differentiate them because same
attribute values for all the
tuples.
So in that case general
condition but then we will go
for a more restrictive
conditions for termination.
So we will stop if the number of
instances is less than some
threshold.
So if there are only 10 tuples
in certain paths, we don't go
proceed further and then we meet
also run Kai Square test to
check if the class and then the
attributes do have some level of
dependence.
Otherwise, if they are
independent then also we are
going to stop and then we also
checked the Gini or other
impurity measures and we see
that the gain that we are
getting is very small.
It is only .01 so we can specify
such criteria and thereby we are
going to, uh, going to stop
early and it is also possible
that sometimes we make take a
similar thing but we can do it
differently.
We build the entire tree and
then we start studying, which is
the part of the tree that we
should prove so that we can do
it in many ways.
So this is becoming essentially
a bottom up way of pruning.
So we can keep, we can keep
checking with some test records
and see if we prune some
subtree.
Is it going to improve so that
is how we are going to we run
the tree on some test data and
we start looking for the places
where there are errors and there
we are going to trim and replace
it by a leaf.
So what is the advantage of a
decision tree?
It is relatively inexpensive and
it can, if it's a simple tree
and then it is interpretable and
by and large it is fast and it
also gets reasonable accuracy.
OK, so that is about the
decision trees that we wanted to
talk.
We will go into the new topic.
So which is a rule based
classifier?
So so before I go there, I'm not
seeing any messages.
I hope it is clear, so I'll I'll
proceed to the.
Uh, OK, Mr Rizwan wants to ask a
question, so I'm going to mute
unmute people.
Mr This one, please speak.
Hi.
Thanks for meeting with her.
So my question is not related
to, you know the topic, but if
you can see my message, I think
there was some issue with the
one of the question of quiz.
Yeah, yeah.
Leads questions.
OK, you you posted a quiz
question in the OK the following
selected aggregation and got
zero marks MM seeing anything.
Yeah.
So you're saying that you
selected aggregation for that
question, but got zero must.
OK, then why don't you write?
Absolutely, yeah.
Uh, OK, OK, so so let me let me
check that.
Mr Richman, I I don't want to
answer that question right away,
but you, but it will be great if
you can send me a mail regarding
the same.
So that will remind me to look
at it.
I'll do that, Sir.
I I'll send the email with the
proof that what I had selected.
Thank you.
Yeah, you can send the mail.
I I hope you know that my mail
ID it is there in the canvas
page so you can see.
Sure, I'll check that.
Thank you so much.
Alright, so I'm muting people.
Ohh.
Yes.
Any other question?
So for me it shows filling
missing values the correct
answer.
It says missing values is the
correct answer.
Yes.
OK.
OK, I'll check that up also.
So it is showing the missing
values.
Missing values is also OK.
OK, missing values, filling the
missing value is not a
transformation. OK.
Umm, OK.
OK, fine.
Aggregation.
Each aggregation can be if is OK
OK, let me see.
Let me see. OK.
The feeling that you or should
be the part of the data
transformation, right, that is
the clear shot feeling missing
Which one, Mr DINKAR?
value with the feeling missing
values that should be the part
Missing value, yes. Mm-hmm.
of the data transformation for
sure, right?
OK.
I'll.
I'll come back.
So if there is a problem with
that, so we'll, I'll see that,
OK, alright.
Yes.
OK, I'll let me go back so find.
So if that is so, then maybe
I'll go to the next topic.
And which is the which is rule
based classification.
OK, so rule based classification
needs it's.
It's actually a cousin of
decision tree based methods, so
this is also both of them are
highly interpretable.
Both of them are highly
interpretable.
Because they create a model
which a domain expert can easily
see and say whether it is good
or bad.
Uh, these are these are pretty
tricky thing.
Domain expert can never validate
this and similarly this also is
becomes difficult, though it
graphically may be able to see
something in neural networks,
even the graphically there is a
there is a little scope.
So, so now.
Now let's see how does a rule
based classifier work?
So a rule based classifier looks
like if then else rules that you
see in the programming
languages.
So it is pretty much like the
rules that we have in
programming languages.
So the rule will have something
like an antecedent.
So it is a LHS or antecedent.
Antecedent and then this is RHS.
Consequent, OK, so you can have
the rules of this phone, so we
can create the rules saying that
this is this attribute is this,
and this attribute is this.
And then this is the we can say
these are the class labels.
So now let us say this is the
training data we got.
And we can drop this attribute.
So now we have 4 attributes and
we have a class label.
So somehow, let's say somehow we
got this somehow we got.
Some set of rules.
So this looks like a highly
interpretable and useful model
that we can create from a
training data, and the this is
this is a rule based classifier,
so this is becoming a rule based
classifier.
So now the question is that what
can we do once we have a rule
based classifier?
So this is the test data.
That's stupid.
So we can check how it is
working.
So first tuple has got a give
birth is equal to no and can fly
is equal to yes.
So this should be.
Rule 1 should be.
Rule should be one should be
finding the class and the class
label should be bird.
Great.
So.
So that seems to be good.
Now let's look at the next one.
The blood type is warm, so give
birth is equal to yes and can
fly is equal to no.
So Rule 1 does not work live in
water is no so Rule 2 does not
work, but give birth is yes and
black type is warm.
So it is a mammal, so we it is
triggered Rule 3 and we are
classifying this as my mom.
So it worked well.
So far.
So, given a rule, given some
test data, so we want to see
what makes a rule good.
So there are two parameters or
two metrics we can use to check
whether the rule is.
How good is the rule?
So say status is single and
evade is no.
So this is what we are taking.
So we are looking at 1234.
So it is covering 4 out of 10
tuples so it be it has got a
coverage of 40% and but then out
of these four tuples 2 have got
no and two have got yes.
So this is like 2 out of four.
So this is that goodness
accuracy is 50%.
So so we want to look at,
evaluate the rule based on both
and.
So so now, now let us go.
Let us go little further.
So we got more test data.
So cool.
So lemur, the blood type is warm
and gives birth is yes.
So Rule 3 is getting triggered.
And we classify this as moment.
So now let us look at the 4th
one.
The turtle that is the second
One South.
The blood type is cold and gives
birth is no and then can fly is
no so rule one is not triggered.
Rule 2 is not triggered and the
turtle gives birth.
Is no Rule 3 is not triggered,
but Rule 4 is triggered.
Can fly is no and then live in
water sometimes, so it can be.
It can be a reptile.
Or can be an amphibian.
OK, let let us not get into the
biology because you can see that
many reptiles or amphibians, so
that is why this cannot created.
But but then let us go with the
just like a just go with the
data.
So let's say that it is
triggering 2 two rules.
That is, it is triggering Rule 4
and Rule 5.
OK, now let us look at the last
one.
Third one, the blood type is
cold.
It is not helping anyway.
There is no rule with blood
type.
Cold gives birth is yes, but
blood type is warm so it doesn't
work so.
So The thing is rule one rule
two, rule 3 rule ruled out Rule
4 is ruled out because it gives
birth.
It's yes, and it lives in water,
so rule 5 is ruled out, so it
triggers none of the rules.
So we got a problem.
Why not our five lives in a
water sometimes?
It's it lives in water all the
time, so it you cannot say that
it lives in water only
sometimes.
OK.
OK, so so now we have a problem
that is we there are some tuples
for which the ambiguity is
coming because there are
multiple rules are getting
triggered.
So we need to find out which is
the right rule.
And there are tuples for which
no rule is getting triggered, so
we need to see whether we can
fix the classifier with respect
to these problems.
Even the first rule is satisfied
is still, it will go further and
it will check whether anything
else is also matching.
Right, Sir.
Ohh, now the question is yes, we
can always say that the moment
First Rule is satisfied stop
the.
That is possible.
That can be that is part of the
solution, not the problem.
Yes, we can say that.
So in that case we need to have
a mechanism to say that some of
OK.
the rules are more important and
then somebody should come and
say that some rules are more
important and put them at the
top and some rules have a lesser
importance.
So put them at the bottom, so
that should be.
That is one possible approach.
So yes, so we are going to see
what are the, what are the ways
So.
in which we are going to fix
this.
So we would like the rule based
classifier to be mutually
exclusive.
You should create the rules
which are mutually exclusive, so
that is every record is covered
by at most one rule.
At most one rule, not more than
that.
OK, the rules are independent of
each other and then ray record
triggers no more than one.
So that is 11 desirable feature
that we would like.
So it avoids the problem that we
had and we also want it to be
exhausting.
So that is, if we take counts
for every possible combination
of attributes.
So in fact, so that is the
record should trigger at least
one rule.
So we want we want we want.
Just to pull two trigger.
Exactly one rule.
So that is the that is in fact
our aim.
So.
So the point is, we may or may
not be able to reach that point,
because if we reach there, it
is.
It is possible that we may end
up with very large predicates
because test data may have 20,
so training data may have 20
attributes, but we may thought
we may have found a way whereby
simple rule is about to is doing
a discrimination between the
classes.
But then if we demand that
exactly one rule.
So in that case, in that case,
we may end up with the very big
predicates in order to on the
left side, the antecedent will
become very big, so the so more
like we may want to relax one of
these.
But but then we are looking at
the concerns that we have seen
with the classifier that we have
seen.
So now let us look at Decision
Tree.
So we constructed.
Sir, I just want to do so by
predicates.
What exactly you mean, Sir?
Like the combination that you
have.
Ohh.
OK, OK.
OK.
You are.
You're saying, what is the
meaning of the word predicate?
OK, OK.
So it is.
It is essentially things like
uh, things like condition, which
Yeah.
becomes true or false because
for example this is.
Refund is equal to no.
I can say that this is 1
predicate, right?
So this is becoming this can
have a value of true or false.
OK, OK.
Right, right, right.
Uh, so I had one.
So, so essentially all the
elements that are constituting
the rule on the left side which
are separated by the end.
So we are calling them each one
as we can call that as a
predicate, right?
Uh, I had one question on the
last slide.
OK, got it.
Yes, previous slide, right, yes.
Yeah.
So, uh, if we go, if we go by
these two rules that they are
mutually exclusive and
exhaustive.
You know that these are not the
rules.
Essentially, these are something
which are more desirable.
That is what we are seeing.
These are not really rules, so
we are saying that if these
OK, so so the the last.
characteristics are there then
what we are saying is that we
And.
the problem that we had would
not have occurred.
Yeah, go ahead.
OK, OK.
So.
So the in the previous slide the
turtle example, so it was a
So best.
hitting two of the roles, so
it's OK that it was hitting two
of the rules, but it's desirable
that it hit only one.
Yes, that is because.
See The thing is, unless
somebody is coming to you and
telling that one rule is more
important than the other, then
you don't know how to classify
turtle, right?
Umm.
So that is, that is what it is.
So based on based on these two
characteristics, that means our
rules were like we need to
refine them.
They are not complete.
Yeah.
Yeah, right.
That is right, that is in fact
what we want to say, that the
rules have not reached.
We we want to refine the rules
or we want to refine the entire
rule set.
We are going to see what we need
to do so that the so that it
works like a classifier which is
giving us a single class label.
So we are going to find ways to
do that, yes.
Except.
OK. Yes.
So what more question when we
are setting this rule example a
refund is there?
Yes.
Can we combine 2 rules together
and to find an example a squal
to zero and B is equal to 1 and
then we're giving you a glass to
Umm.
me?
Yes, that is, that is what we
were doing here, right?
We were doing, we are combining
multiple attributes so that is
that anyway, yes, we we will
have to do right, yes.
Sure.
OK, so now let us let us see.
Let us say we have this decision
tree.
We know how to build this
decision tree.
We have used it using a
heuristic, either Gini or
entropy or whatever.
So we build that.
So now our next question is that
can we derive the rules from
here?
Yes, we can do that right from
Decision Tree to rules is very
simple.
So all we need to do is that we
have to take each branch or or
we have to.
We have to find the path to
reach each leaf.
So essentially we have to trace
the path.
Do each leaf.
We have 4 leaves here so we got
4 rules.
So refund is equal to yes is no
then refund is equal to no and
then this is marital status.
Single diverse taxable income
less than 80K?
No.
So we got all the rules.
That is essentially this is
representing 1234 right 1234.
4 rules to represent the four
leaf nodes.
And what are the advantages that
we are getting?
This is that the rules are
mutually exclusive.
And rules or exhausted.
But exhaustive to the extent
that we consider those
attributes in the decision tree
because we had three attributes
in the toy data set and we
considered them in addition
three.
But then when we have a larger
data sets with far more
attributes, we may drop some of
the attributes while
constructing the tree may not
use them because we think that
they're not improving either
Gini or entropy or any any way
they are going to improve the
quality of the.
So in such cases such cases, the
question of exhaustive becomes a
difficult thing.
Actually, exhaustive is treated
like this.
So you have, let us say, let us
say, training data.
So training data uh is having a
of some tuples, some some
attributes had some attributes
and.
Attributes and test day test
tuple.
Had all those attributes.
So then for creating exhaustive
rules, what you need is only on
one of the attributes, the
rules.
All the conditions should be
considered so that is sufficient
to create exhaustive rule set.
Is that clear?
So for example, so here.
Here, suppose that we have rules
saying that.
Give both.
Is equal to yes, implies mammal.
And give both is equal to noon.
Implies.
Let us say give birth is new
implies.
Let's see.
Ohh bird right bird.
So this is this is in a in the
sense of the rule based
classifier.
This is exhausting because any
test tuple that comes that will
have either give birth is equal
to yes, or give birth is equal
to no.
So what that means is that the
moment that attribute is given,
we can determine what is the
class, because it is either
mammal or bird.
So in that sense, we are never
going to say no, we are always
getting a class label.
So so it is never going to
happen.
For example, in this case he
could not give a class for the
dog shark because for give birth
is equal to yes and no.
Both of them are not covered
because give birth no is covered
with some other attributes and
so so so the point is that you
are not able to get for one
single attribute clarity even
when you are giving it.
For example, give birth is equal
to no.
You have can fly is equal to
yes, but can fly is equal to no
it is not there.
So, OK, give birth is equal to
new can fly is equal to no.
OK, fine.
So but give birth is black type
one is there but give birth.
Yes.
And black type hold is given,
then it would have become
exhaustive.
Is that clear?
So you don't need really that if
there are 100 attributes, you
don't need to cover 2 to the
power of 100 rules.
Can you repeat?
So all you need to make sure
that at least few attributes for
which we are we are going to get
the values in the test tuples
they have been exhaustively
covered.
So then then it is never going
to say no, it is going to give
So Sir said.
the answer whether the quality
of the answer we will see there
is a still the problem, but then
it is exhaustive.
Yes, yes, someone has a
question.
So, yeah.
Please go ahead.
Yeah, Sir.
So it means that whatever rule
we are making, those are
mutually exclusive.
I mean to say that suppose for
one tuple a, can we have two
rules satisfied?
No, no.
See that they're mutually
exclusive.
We have not even talked about.
We only talked about exhausting,
so mutually exclusive, saying
that they have to be completely
independent and that is not the
case with the R4 and R5 because
they're talking about different
attributes, but those attributes
may exist for some new test
tuple or all the attributes may
exist.
So Miss Surbhi, are we In Sync?
Because, OK, so that is
different.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
We are only talking about
exhaustive.
The exhaustive is it is not
necessary that if you got 100
attribute training data you need
to create really 2 to the power
of 100 rules.
So all you need to do is that
you need to create only the
rules on at least one attribute.
All the possible combinations
you should be able to get
because if the test tuple is
having that attribute we are
going to get the result.
OK.
So OK, then we will proceed
further.
OK.
So what we are saying is that we
are looking at this.
So we are seeing that in case of
a decision tree because the
decision tree whatever attribute
is there, we are considering all
the possible values.
For example, refund is equal to
yes no both of them are
considered fully and so So what
that means is that when we get a
new tuple so it has to be the
refund is equal to yes or refund
is equal to no and one of the
marital status should exist so
so the point is that if those
attributes are given so we
should be able to get the class.
Now let us see the rules given
me.
The decision trees sometimes
tend to be longer because the
decision trees sometimes may go
for depth of 45610 and all that.
So so suppose that we may want
to simplify the rules so that
they become more interpretable.
So now let us say this is the
initial rule, OK refund is equal
to no end status is equal to
married.
It is no.
But now let us say we got
another rule that is saying the
refund is equal to yes in place
status is the class label is no.
So now from this now let me call
this Rule X and this as rule Yi
can combine rule X and rule Y
and create rule jet.
Right.
You can see this doesn't matter.
Whatever is the refund, whether
refund is equal to yes and
status is equal to married
because when refund is equal to
yes, it implies no means that
refund is equal to yes even if
the status is married then it is
still no right so now refund is
equal to no and then status is
married then also no.
So when status is married,
whether refund is equal to yes
or no, it is still no.
So that means we can create a
simplified rule which is rule
checked which is status is equal
to married implies the class
label is no.
So once we start simplifying the
rules, we may not get mutually
exclusive.
And then exhaustive rules,
because once we simplify them
much further, then we may end up
with the rules which will get
into the problems.
So so two ways in which we can
solve them is that if the rules
are not mutually exclusive as
one of you have already pointed
out, why not order the rules?
OK, order the rules.
So somebody has to say which
rule is more important than the
other.
So that way First Rule is going
to be first Rule is going to be
a is going to be accepted or we
can keep all the rules and then
we can see whether.
So suppose that there are C1 and
C2 are the two classes and it
test tuple.
Triggers.
Fire rules.
And C1 is triggered by two rules
and C2 is triggered by three
rules.
Then we can use it as a voting
scheme and say that test tuple.
Belongs to C2 because more rules
of C2 are getting triggered than
the C1.
So that is one approach.
And then and the other one
other.
This is solving the problem of
mutually exclusive.
But when the rules are not
mutually exclusive, say rules
are not exhaustive, then what we
can have is that we can simply
have a default class.
So thereby if no rules
triggered, we are going to call
it by sending.
So now let us say we have
prioritized the rules and there
is a ranking for the rules.
So now the rules are so then
what is going to happen?
So Turtle will become it
riptide.
Because this is the ranking.
So they ranking is in along this
line.
So we will say this is this is
becoming a reptile.
OK, so when we are creating the
ranking or ordering for the
rules, we can take 2 approaches.
One needs one needs a rule based
ordering, so we can see that
some rule is more important than
the other.
So we are saying that this is R1
not two or three or four, so
that can be one approach or we
can do a class based order.
So the class based ordering is
more often helpful when we are
trying to diagnose.
He critical.
Epidemic.
So in that case, what we are
saying is that first we want to,
if we have a smallest suspicion
about a person, so we'll
straight away, put that person
in the quarantine for one week.
So that is that is the way we
are going to.
So we are not going to
complicate further saying that
because the importance is that
the disease should not spread.
So any suspicion you have about
the epidemic with certain person
so immediately you start putting
that person in quarantine.
So this is this is an example of
a class based order rule based
ordering.
You can start doing in many
commercial situations.
So for example, there is always
a consideration whether this
person will buy the product or
not.
So you can start considering all
possible reasons, because there
is nothing critical either, so
it's nothing life threatening.
So you can always think in terms
of if you think some rule has a
higher quality irrespective of
the class you want to trigger it
first.
OK, so now now I hope the idea
of the rules and idea of
But sorry the one.
resolving the order of the rules
and then looking at the quality
of the rules is all clear.
So we will look at some more
metrics related to the rules.
So before that we can take if
there are questions I'll take.
Search the.
Otherwise, we can take 5 minute
break, right?
Say I have one note.
So can you please go to the
preview?
Yes, yes, there go to the
previous slide, right.
In that reptile or that MBA in
this example, is there right?
OK, OK.
Put them inside.
So you want me to go to the this
slide, this one?
Yeah.
So here how we do with the both
the R4 and R5 rules apply over
Yes.
here right?
No, no, because we are saying
Rule 4 is more important than
Rule 5.
That is what now?
So this is one way of resolving
it.
I'm not saying that biology,
that is the way they do it, but
then, yes, suppose that in some
problem that you have in domain
OK.
a ranking is there and then you
take it and in any case I have
already given you the example
where if you are diagnosing a
OK.
critical epidemic, so you are
always going to give some higher
priority to one class over the
other, right?
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
OK.
Is it clear?
Yeah.
Yes, yes, yeah.
OK, OK.
But Sir, here, here I am not
getting one thing between the
So we.
difference between rule based
and class based that what we are
OK, OK.
doing extra in the class based.
No, no, no, no.
Left side is a rule based
ordering, so we are saying the
Rule 1 to Rule 4 and then we are
saying the ranking.
So like here we are giving the
ranking and based on the rank
the the rule will be used.
So first, truly, if it is not a
place then try to use second
And what will be there? Yeah.
rule.
Otherwise, try to use third rule
and finally go to the 4th.
Is that clear?
Yeah.
So it is for the rule based
ordering, but what about class
Yeah, class based.
based ordering?
We are saying that the class
label is no or yes, so the no
has got higher priority than
yes.
So then we are going to put all
the nodes at the top and yes at
the bottom.
Oh, OK, got it.
Alright, so you can see that the
yes got shifted in the right set
of the rules.
OK, OK, got it.
OK.
So let us take 5 minute break.
That one?
One question, Sir.
Yes.
OK, so whenever we are making
this rules, this is not we are
not going to write it right?
Like with the training data,
that algorithm is going to
create all these sets, right,
Sir?
Yes, that is correct.
Yes, yes, yes.
OK, so the ordering I mean how
how are we going to give the
weightage for this?
This is the ordering or.
See this when you're writing a
program.
Obviously you're going to tell
what is the ordering that you
want to give, so you can.
You can find the mechanisms to
tell what is the what is it that
you want to give.
Otherwise you will ask the
machine to give the rules
without ordering, and then you
manually order them right.
OK, it's not like, OK.
Got it.
Sir, I thought like a.
No, you can.
You can see see and Mr
Sebastian.
Nothing stopping saying that any
rule which is got a highest
accuracy and then the coverage I
want to give it the so the we
are going to learn some metrics
I you can say that based on this
metric you want to order when
that is your call.
I'm not saying that should be
the one, but you can do that
right accuracy fine.
Go for it.
Can you tell?
Sir, for the class one, the
class ordering.
So like the column.
How we are designating that this
is my class and then based on
that we are procuring our rules.
So like if.
You know you are.
You are looking at the current
slide the the this slide.
This is the one you are asking.
I know.
Yes, exactly.
So the class based.
So in this like how we are
basically classifying that
column to be a class and then
based on that we are going to
restructure the rules.
So can you just enlighten that?
No, no.
Now you tell me.
Suppose that there is a critical
epidemic is spreading.
So what should the doctor
prioritize?
Like.
So whether the Class 0 or class
yes.
Uh, yes, but.
Last year, slightest suspicion
the doctor should say
quarantine, right?
Exactly, Sir. Right.
So now you are.
You are clarity that which class
should be at the top right.
OK.
OK, OK.
But it's OK.
Thank you, Sir.
For that, there are some.
OK, let's get started.
So we will look at some methods
to evaluate the rules.
So there are some methods that
have been proposed and we'll see
how they work.
So suppose that there is a.
There is a training data.
With the.
With two classes.
So what are they?
Positive class and negative
class positive and negative
right.
And now let us say there are how
many.
Let us take a simple example.
The training data has 200 tuples
with the 100 positive and
hundred negative.
And we created a rule and then
what the rule is doing is that
rule is picking up 50 tuples.
And out of these, so we are
saying we created Rule 1.
Rule one such that something is
positive.
OK.
So this is the rule that we
created.
It is picking A50 tuples out of
them, 40 or positive and 10 not
negative.
So then we will say that the
rule one has given us a foil
gain of.
So how many positive prime is
40?
So it is giving us a the number
of positive tuples that it has
picked up, compare and then we
compare it with the negative
tuples that it picked up.
So it is getting 50 here.
Sorry, 40 days 40.
And then this is 40 by 50.
This is 100 by 200.
So we will compute this and say
that the rule one is giving us
so much frigging.
So now let us consider another
Rule Rule 2.
So this works like this.
So it is saying it is also
saying positive, but then this
is picking up only let's say 5
to apples.
And all five are positive, and
nobody's nothing is negative.
So so now the question will be
is rule one better or Rule 2
better?
Whoops.
Anybody wants to say rule one.
June 1.
I.
The rule to.
OK.
Yes, in fact, that is what the
expert thinks, because they
think that it is doing a better
generalization compared to the
rule.
Two Rule 2 is actually very,
very selective.
And then so it may be may even
be overfitting.
So we don't know.
But then if it is, if it is
still be so selective, people
say the the the they think that
it should be giving lesser
weightage.
So in this case, what is the
foil gain?
Foil gain will be 5 multiplied
by.
Log 2 of 15 by 5, right.
So 5 by 5.
So let me get this 15 by 5 minus
log 2 of 100 by 200.
So this is the way we compute
the end the foil gain for the
1st R1 is going to be higher
than the foil gain for the
second one.
So we can even do the
computation.
So let us let us also do a
computation.
We can Simply put.
How does coming positive plus
negative as five only that after
log figure?
Just one minute.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll.
I'll do this.
I'll do it on this slide.
So we are saying that the
training data is.
Training data is 100 positive
and hundred negative right?
So there are 200 tuples, 200
training datas and the first
rule is picking up 50 tuples and
out of them out of them 40 are
positive and 10 or negative and
Rule 2 is picking up five to
five tuples and all of them are
positive.
So the file gain.
For R1 E equal to 40 multiplied
by.
Log 2 of 40 by 50.
Minus log 2 of 100 by 200.
So so this is this is equal to
let us 40 by 50 is .8, right,
OK.
So let us do the log 24.8 or if.
Two later, so 0.8 log divided by
two log, so minus .32 right?
So minus 1.32.
And this is minus one, right, so
1 -, 0.32.
So this is equal to .68 into 4.
Is 27.2 right?
OK, so this is the foil gain for
Rule 1.
Rule 2 is 5 multiplied by log 25
by 5 minus log 2 of 100 by 200.
OK, So what is this equal to?
This is equal to 1, so this will
become zero, right?
5 Multiple this is equal to 5 *
1, so that is fine.
So is this clear or someone has
a questions?
I hope it is clear right.
And you're.
The foil foil gain.
How it is working?
I said just one thing.
So 100 plus you are considering
the one which from the class you
are getting is yes, right.
And the 100 minus is from the
class which is classified as.
No.
Yes, yes, there are two class
problem.
Is that right?
We are doing it for two class
problem.
Exactly.
So in the training data, we got
a balanced 100 positive tuples,
Exactly. Yeah.
hundred negative tuples, and
rule one has picked up fifty
FedEx.
among them and Rule 2 picked
only five among.
Got it.
So we are comparing which rule
to pick rule one or Rule 2.
So we are foil, gain algorithm
is going with Rule 1.
Sir, you're 50 + 50.
Sir, if Singh.
Rule 1 picked up form positive
as well as negative tuples as
well or.
Yes, yes, it is picked up 50
tuples altogether from 200
tuples and out of them forty
turns out to be positive and 10
200, OK.
turned out to be negative.
But.
Uh.
So let's say it was not 100 and
it split.
Let's say it was 130 and 70
then.
Then the root will be different
slightly.
I'm in the same formula we will
use, so let me create another
slide.
OK, so let me erase you the
data.
OK, so all that you are saying
is, uh.
So so the training data has got
training data, has got 200
tuples out of them, 130 are
positive and 70 or negative and
then say rule one and rule two
are similar.
So the formula is that the file
gain for file gain for rule one
will be 40 multiplied by log 2
of 40 by 50 minus log 2 of 130
by 200.
OK, this is.
I hope it is clear right.
The person who I forgot the name
of, the person who brought up
Yep.
Yes.
Yes, Sir.
that one.
Yeah, just keep.
The only thing I have in like
why we are only considering the
Yes, yes.
positive tuples like why we are
taking only log 2 of 130 by 200
not log 2 of 70 by 200.
Ah, OK, OK. OK.
So suppose that you have created
a rule of negative class.
Then you will take that.
Suppose that something implies
negative, so then you take that
OK. OK.
negative.
That we.
So essentially whatever the
class that the rule is
triggering.
So that is what.
So we are assuming that the
positive class is more important
and then we went with it.
But suppose that the rule is
triggering negative class,
saying that if these attributes
are there, take this as
negative.
Then you need to do all the
calculations assuming the new
class.
Uh, so is there anything like
that?
If foil gain for R1 is high,
then we need to when then then
the rule is very important or
one is important rather than not
to visit like that or.
See, that is what.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, nobody.
Nobody will come to you a domain
and is going to say how to give
importance to the rules, but
then this is one thing which the
data scientists found to be
useful while creating these
running these algorithms that
the file gain is going to be in
general with the data sets it it
seems to have a give way
interesting rules.
So this is pretty much saying
like the decision tree.
Also, we said we we should not
do overfitting, so we should
stop early.
So they we were using several
major so similarly this is your
major which is saying that OK go
for the rule which is having a
superior coverage along with the
accuracy.
Thinking.
It's a.
Yes, yes, yes, someone has a
question.
So similar to foil gain, OK, we
have also we have also got
another criteria which is called
foil prune.
Sir, I have a question.
So so we need the calculation.
Yes.
We found that 27 and five,
right.
Hmm. Yes.
What?
What does that signifies,
basically?
No, it signifies that the rule
when has got a better foil gain
and should be preferred if you
think that the foil gain is a
good heuristic.
OK.
Fine, yeah.
Then another thing that people
do is that we use the foil gain
on the training tuples because
it is, we do not have the test
data, so we are only building
the rules from the training
data, say after the rule is
built.
Suppose that I got a rule which
is which runs like this.
So for we, if we need to analyze
while gain right the so we need
to have more than one rules and
then only we can compare them.
Hmm.
But yeah, I mean having a foil
gain for a single rule doesn't
That is correct.
That is correct, yes, but.
signify anything, right?
That is correct.
Yes, foil gain for single rule.
Of.
It can signify only to the
extent that it is combining
coverage and accuracy well, and
it is.
It is giving a formula of which
combines both of them and and
our in.
Both of them are desirable
features.
Let's say we believe both of
them are desirable, then
obviously, uh higher number
indicates that something good
about the rule, is it not?
Higher with respect to what,
Sir, when we say higher number,
if we have just one rule, right,
even five is higher if we have
Hmm.
you know when we don't have a
range, right, so.
OK.
So you are saying no other rule
exist?
OK, no other rule exist then
yes, fine.
Yeah, correct.
So OK, then there is nothing
that we can do, right? Yes.
Yeah, it's it's probably works
better in the comparison.
Individually.
It has no relevance in my.
Meet and see.
See in fact, the entire thing.
For example, the Gini or
entropy, they are all for the
comparison, right?
Because we are comparing, we
have multiple attributes.
We are comparing the how much
entropy we are gaining by going
for each one of the attributes
and we are picking up whichever
Correct.
is giving us the best.
Makes sense?
Yeah.
OK, so now now let us let us
look at a situation.
Suppose that we created a rule.
Rules.
Uh, let us say, uh attribute one
is equal to X.
And attribute 2 is equal to Y
and attribute 3 is equal to jet
implies positive class.
OK, so now now what we have is
that we, we are testing this on
the test data.
So at this point, we bring in a
metric called foil prune.
So this is working.
Let us say this is working.
So far so good.
So now let us say it is.
It is a selecting, let us say 50
tuples OK and then it is giving
us an accuracy of.
40.
And then 10, let us see.
OK, so now now let us say we
prune, prune one of the one of
them.
Let us say we prune.
We prune this part and now we
got a simpler rule, so this will
have a better coverage, right?
So we are testing now.
It's a now it is covering.
Now it is covering let's say 100
tuples and out of them 85.
Or positive and 15 or negative.
So now the foil prune in this
case is foil prune for this one
is 40 -, 10 / 40 + 10.
So this is .6 and this one is 85
-, 15 / 85 + 15.
So this is .7.
So what we see is that the rule
is getting better when we prune,
so file prune is saying that if
we are getting a pruned rule
with higher foil prune value
then just go and prune that.
So this is generally this is
done recommended to be done on
independent set of test tools.
No, Sir.
I have a question here like
whatever things we are doing
right now, we are just assuming
that it will fall into only two
buckets like binary
classification like what?
Yes, yes. OK.
What is the like?
So these things doesn't apply
when let's say the
classification needs to be done
on two or more, right?
No, no.
Suppose that there are five
classes that are possible, so
five classes.
What you can do is that your
rule will only indicate one
class, right?
And So what you can say is that
that class you call it as a
positive class and every other
class has a negative class.
Mr Parikh, it then we can do it
right.
OK, OK.
So say for sorry for for the
case what we are discussing for
OK.
Yeah. Yes.
like say positive negative and
suppose there there there might
be a rule which will not give
any output of that.
Then I will do that.
No, no, no.
If if we root see we are
starting with a training data
and training data, every tuple
we are assuming that there is a
class label.
So if we are got, we have got
some customers for our company
and we know who whom we could
sell the product successfully
and we whom we could not sell
the product successfully.
So we take only them as training
data.
We so we know whether the person
bought or we did not buy.
So if there is somebody whom you
don't know, then that person
obviously will not help you in
building a model, right?
So the class label is known,
then only we will start building
the model.
The training data.
Mr Willandra, are we In Sync?
Yeah, it's no.
So what I was asking is
basically different.
So for example, we are writing a
rule wherein we are finding the
positive right.
Yes.
So that rule will give either
positive or negative in case if
Yes.
the rule will give positive,
negative and unknown.
Something like that.
No, no.
What will be the case?
OK, OK.
So no.
OK.
OK, Paul, unknown is it cannot
give unknown because clearly in
the training data every tuple
has got a class label.
So you can you can so so you can
you are going to obviously the
Translate well, OK, got it.
create the rules.
So what can happen?
Is that suppose the rule selects
50 tuples out of than 25 or
Umm.
positive and 25 are negative.
So in that case, we need to
think in terms of should we
OK.
consider this rule or simply
look at something else?
Something else?
OK, got it.
So similar to foil gain, we got
another statistic which is
called likelihood ratio.
This looks a little bit like a
chi square approach, So what it
does is that it is going to
compute expected and observed.
So so now now it goes like this.
Suppose that we have got
training data with the.
200 tuples and out of them
hundred are positive and hundred
are negative and then rule one
is triggering 50 tuples is
selecting 50 tuples and out of
them 40 or positive and and 10
are negative.
So what we do is that this is
this is the observed.
Now we compute the expected.
Suppose we create a random dumb
rule.
So what it will get, it will get
50, so we should get 25 positive
and 25 negative, right?
Because training data has 100
positive and hundred negative,
so a random rule is going to
give 25 positive and 25
negative.
So now we compare Rule 1
likelihood ratio statistic is
that it is comparing the expect
observed with respect to the
expected.
So now this is going to create a
formula which is saying that
summation.
So we can remove the summation
so.
So there are two rules here.
There are two classes.
So this will come out to class.
One has got 40 to apples.
And multiplied by log two of
UH-40 by 25.
Bless Glass two has 10 tuples
multiplied by.
Log 2 of 10 by 25 so we compute
this so the higher the
likelihood ratio statistic, the
rule turns out to be better.
Again, this is also using the
same logic which is based on.
The coverage and accuracy of
both of them come together.
The rule gets better.
So you can you you can do the
calculation I hope or we can so
so this is.
So there are classifier rule
based classifiers.
So some of them depend on direct
methods, so they extract rules
directly from the data.
And then there are others which
use indirect approach.
So the first constructed
decision tree or construct a
neural network, and from there
they're going to derive.
So the C 4.5 derives it from the
decision.
So for the direct method, there
is a algorithm that is called as
a sequential covering algorithm.
So what it does is that it the
IT learns the rules
sequentially.
And the such that for every
class it will cover as many
tuples of class that class and
possibly none of the other
classes.
So so suppose that if I have to
draw it as a picture.
So what I'm going to do is that
the first time going to create a
rule which is like this.
Suppose that there are two
attributes, so let me put this
is attribute 1.
And this is attribute.
And we have some training data 7
tuples.
So here we are getting clearly a
rule which is pure.
So we are seeing that by drawing
line here we are getting 2
positive tuples and zero
negative tuples.
So we we have learned and then
we can we have the evaluation
measures.
So we look, keep looking for
them and then once the rule is
learned, once it is learned, the
tuples covered by the rule are
removed.
And what we will do the
remaining tuples we are going to
create another rule or and then
we proceed.
So again, we once the second
rule is created, all the tuples
covered by the second rule or
removed.
So we keep we come to a
condition where there are no
more training rig examples or
the quality of the rules.
He's below threshold.
So so this is the this is the
approach.
So in a decision tree, so the
typical way we proceed is we go
with a breadth approach.
And the rules.
So essentially we are trying to
find many rules at the same
time, but then this is going by
depth approach.
So it is trying to find a rule
first the entire path it wants
to trace and wants to get a
rule.
Then it is going to see if it
can find more.
So so now suppose this is the
data that we have.
So we are looking at the
examples covered by rule one,
rule two Rule 3 and we are going
to remove those those and then
keep the rest.
These are these are OK.
So take it that the there are
also negative tuples in the data
set and so there are both types
of examples, but then we are
taking the rules.
Uh, remove the only the tuples.
This is.
And whatever rule we have picked
up, remove the tuples
corresponding to that tuple that
rule.
So we can see suppose that we
got a data set like this.
So suppose we have created this
rule.
Then we can think in terms of
pruning it, right.
And for the pruning it so now
now the accuracy of the
innermost rule is the best.
The coverage of the outermost
rule is the best, so we are
going for combination and we are
going with a rule which is which
is going to be.
Uh, it essentially the one which
satisfies the heuristics,
whatever heuristic we want to
consider foil or likelihood or
whatever.
So another example of indirect.
So so far I hope it is clear.
OK.
So we will proceed to a a new
topic.
So we have learned so far.
No, we have learned so far 2
classifiers right.
And in each one, actually each
classifier we can by using
different heuristics or
different approaches we can
build multiple classifiers
because it is not necessary that
decision tree has to be one.
We can think in terms of
variations depending on some
criteria.
We can create a new decision, so
it is even possible that
sometimes people do something.
So this is the data set so they
divide it into dataset one and
dataset 2 and create 2
classifiers.
So nothing stops. So there are.
It is possible that we can
create multiple classifiers.
So what is the big deal if we
have the multiple classifiers?
So we can, if we create multiple
classifiers, So what we can do
is that suppose there is a
multiple classifiers and we have
a test tuple.
So we are going to give it to
the each of the classifier and
we are going to see what all
each classifier is going to say
and then we are going it with
the voting.
So we are going to speak the
class which is color which is
recommended by the maximum
number of classifiers so that
can be one approach.
So that is an approach which is
ensemble.
So this can be one approach.
Data we divide multiple
datasets, multiple classifiers
and combine the classifier.
So So what is going to be the
benefit?
Suppose that.
Assume that.
Classifiers or independent?
Independent in the sense that
the way they create the error,
each classifier makes some
mistakes and does something
right, but the way they do it is
independent of the other
classifiers.
So in that case, we can take
this as a probability that
classifier is getting right or
wrong and then we can think in
terms of.
You can think in terms of.
Suppose that each classifier we
create a 25 base classifiers, 25
classifiers.
Each classifier has got 65%
accuracy.
And now what we are saying is
that the classifier ensemble,
what is the accuracy of
ensemble?
So accuracy of ensemble depends
when majority of the classifiers
have to make a mistake, then
only the ensemble will make the
mistake.
So now let us look at it so to
for the ensemble to make mistake
at least.
13 classifiers.
How to go wrong?
So and now we are saying that
the classifiers are independent
of each other.
So what is the probability of 13
classifiers go wrong?
SO25C3C13 right.
So they they because out of the
25 any 13 can go wrong and for
each of those thirteen sets,
what is the probability of this?
So the .35.
Multiplied by 13 and then the
other classifiers, other 12
classifiers are correct.
So, right, so other 12
classifiers are giving correct
answer.
So this is the probability that
13 classifiers.
Or wrong?
Similarly, 14 classifiers can go
wrong, 15 classifiers can go
wrong.
In all these cases, the ensemble
will make mistake.
So if we consider I is equal to
13 to 15 and we start
aggregating the errors that each
possible ensemble is doing each
possible.
Possibility of the error.
For each, it'll be each
combination.
So suppose how many of them go
wrong each time.
So 131415, we keep on trying all
of that.
So the probability adds up to
.06, so this has got a 94%
accuracy.
So the ensemble has got B, base
classifier has 65% accuracy and
the ensemble got 94% accuracy.
Is that clear?
No, Sir.
Can you repeat it?
OK, So what I will do is that
I'm going to do a new problem
because.
So so you will be able to clear.
OK, so so now what I'm saying is
that I have 3 classifiers.
So when you say like 3
independent or let's say an
independent classifiers, does
that mean that they all those
Hmm.
the deploy different
classification technique or the
rules or let's say the decision
trains are completely
independent?
No, no, they can be independent
in way, but for example random
forest, you just all of them are
decision trees.
But then each tree constructs
using different set of
attributes and different set of
tuples.
So that is how it does.
So the way in which we can take
the approach can be but then
then ensemble approach is we are
talking about but then the way
you implement can be different.
And and also it is not easy to
assume that they are the we are
getting independence between the
classifiers, so that may not
always the independence
assumption is a bit loaded one,
but then we are just looking at
the mathematics of ensemble.
If somehow we have created the
independent classifiers, so now
let us say the N symbol is
consisting of three classifiers.
OK, C1C2 and C3.
So now what we are saying is
that all of them have got a
accuracy of 80%.
The all of them have got 80%
accuracy so that is 20% error
rate.
So now let us say we have got a
test tuple.
So so now it is possible that
suppose between C1C2C3, what can
be the answers so so they are
test tuple so they can give a
correct answer or wrong answer.
So correct answer all of them
can give correct answer right
or.
Or.
OK, I'm finally putting one
thing which is WWW.
All of them are wrong.
So now the question is that a
test tuple has come.
So now we have to see what is
the probability of all of them
going wrong.
So now we have to say what is
the probability of?
Ensemble.
Doing going wrong.
So that can happen with this
case.
All of them are wrong or it can
happen with this case.
Two of them are wrong or it this
case two of them are wrong and
in this case two of them are
wrong.
So what is the probability of
all of them going wrong?
It is .2 * .2 * .2 and two of
them were going wrong.
It is two of them are going
wrong .2 square multiplied by .8
and this can happen at in happen
in three ways.
So the probability of ensemble
going wrong is .008.
Plus, let's this is point G04
multiplied by this is 2.4, so
that is 0.008 plus.
0.096 right.
So that is equal to 0 point.
104 so the 20% error rate came
down to 10.4% error rate.
Is this clear?
Understood, Sir.
OK, OK. Alright.
So previously we had used 25 so
it is not possible to explain
all the numbers, but we three we
could see that it is very clear
and so you can think of why and
symbol is giving us a better
accuracy.
No, no.
Let us go to the next problem.
Now suppose that there are, but
then we had taken a very
convenient situation where all
the classifiers have got the
same error rate.
Now, now let us think of a
situation where, again, we are
looking at the we are looking at
an ensemble consisting of three
classifiers.
So this has a 5% error rate.
Classifier 2 got 15% error rate,
classified 3 got 20% error rate.
What is going to happen?
We build a classifier ensemble
and say that go with majority
working.
Somebody wants to make a guess.
Is the question clear?
In somebody's confirmed that the
question is clear.
Uh, yes, I thought the 5% one
would be the ohh optimal.
No, no.
We suppose that we got three.
We built 3 classifiers because
we have many, many methods to
build classifiers.
So we build 3 independent
classifiers somehow.
Now the question is that suppose
the accuracy of three of them is
different.
So then what will be the
ensembles accuracy?
Average of three, Sir.
Like depletion of the three.
Average of the three.
OK, now let us see.
Let us see.
Somebody has guessed it as an.
Better than all the three.
Uh, no, miss GURSIMRAN, what is
the answer?
Should I believe it will be
better than all of three?
It is better than all of three.
OK, OK.
So so now, now let me let me let
us do the calculation.
So then maybe it will help.
So so again, we want the
majority of them have to be,
right, so majority are wrong is
error right majority of error,
all of them them going wrong is
I hope you will agree .05 * .15
* .2 all of them going wrong.
Other one is that .952 of them
are going wrong is .95 + .15 +
.20.
Then another way two of them can
go wrong is .05.
Key there is some problem.
Sir, we are calculating
combination of all right.
Like Pass Pass failed.
Yes, yes, because we what is the
other option we have.
OK.
Somebody wants to do the
calculation.
So the numbers are simple 2015
300.03 so .03 and point.
So this is actually we need to
remove the all we have to
multiply it by 10 to the power
of minus six.
So we are getting 5, 2015, 300
so it is 900 right?
No, no.
1500, right. OK.
So shouldn't there be one more
summation where in like you know
.95 * .85 * .80 sort of a thing.
No, in that case.
See in that case all of them are
right.
So we are going to get the
correct answer right.
We are getting calculating the
error rate.
Uh, OK, welcome. OK.
We are calculating only error
rate.
Yeah.
OK, so this is 300 * .95, so 285
right 285 and then the 00 OK.
Less so.
This is 100 * 85, so 8500 right?
Then this is 75 * 80 + 606,000,
so you can add them up 6015
hundred, 85,000 is 10,016
thousand 44,500.
Multiplied by 10 to the power of
minus six. Right?
So this is equal to 0 point.
0.
445.
Alright, so so far so good.
So far so good.
So now I'm changing this to 3%.
Right.
And then you verify what will
happen to the ensemble.
So once you change that to 3%,
So what will happen is that this
will become equal to three.
So this will become equal to.
900.
And then this is 97 uh, then 97
means 29101 hundred.
Then this is again .03.
So uh, so 85 into .6 is 4851.
Then this is 1200, so this is
3600.
So this will be equal to 900.
This is 30,000 thirty 8700, so
this is 0.0387.
So the ensemble error rate is
more than the error rate of the
C1.
Is it clear?
This is 10 to the power of minus
six is there?
Is that clear?
So if we got a very good single
classifier and we bring it
together with some not so good
classifiers and clean build an
ensemble, it is going to corrupt
the good one.
Are we In Sync or have I lost
somewhere?
Everybody's quite is, is, is
this understood?
If, as long as all the ensemble
members are more.
It.
This calculation we got it, Sir.
Yes, Sir.
How are you?
I I can you repeat?
Yeah, we got this.
I at least I got this
calculation.
What you did?
I mean, we're just trying to
find out like how you finding
Yeah, yeah.
OK.
out the error rate for?
No, no.
There is no formula, but the
concept is that when we are
Umm.
creating an ensemble and suppose
that few of them are very good
and some of them are average or
very bad, then we can't hope to
create an ensemble that is
superior to individual
classifiers.
But then if all of them are
equally bad or equally averaged,
then we can create a better one.
If they are independent of each
other.
Umm.
Yes, like for the second
example, like if you observe the
OK.
3% the other we are getting
three more than three percent.
Three nearly four percent, 4%
for ensemble.
1387.
Yeah.
Yep, you know.
So.
So then The thing is that
essentially C2 and C3 brought
down the C1.
So so now now the people have a
different interpretations for
this.
So they may say that C1 is
really an overfit.
That may be one possibility, or
it is possible that there so
people say that random forest,
in spite of it even random
forest works better because it
is a superior generalization.
That is what some people go
with.
So ensembles do a better
generalization, but then the
interpretations differ, but the
mathematics will work only to
some extent.
Other after that it is becoming
heuristic.
OK, so the next topic is model
evaluation.
So.
So I hope so far I things are
clear.
So we'll proceed to the next
topic.
So just to doubt, so in the
previous it is in it.
I mean, it is very essential
that the classification
techniques are independent to
each other, right?
So, is there any statistical way
to say I mean to prove that it
is independent so that we can
follow this ensemble or?
No, actually actually if if you
get a million records, everybody
becomes helpless.
So.
So The thing is that if you have
a way of see the point that I
think I told you a friend is
that the idea of explainable AI?
Explainable AI is where you can
do a good interpretation, right?
So in such cases, based on your
intuition, you can see that it
is working fine.
Otherwise, what you may have to
do is that given a data set, you
are going to see for each
classifier, what are the things
that it misclassified.
So if the if every classifier is
misclassifying the same thing,
you combine them.
You are going to get no
advantage.
Is that clear, Mr Pranam?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's clear.
You asked the question right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So so there is really nothing
like if there is a formula, then
Thank you.
possibly we will not study
independent classifiers.
So we say that, OK, start
building the ensemble, but there
is really, really there are no
mathematics, don't work there.
And so we we go with the and
people like using.
Many times the random forest
instead of 1 tree they built
many trees and then random
forest use the random forest to
get somewhat better and than.
So that that depends on
essentially random forest means
it selects the subset of
attributes.
So if you have a large number of
set attributes and then you
think all of them are useful,
then that can work better.
OK.
Yeah. OK.
Yeah.
Thank you, Sir.
OK.
So we will look at how to
evaluate a model.
So.
So The thing is that so far we
have been talking about
accuracy.
But then accuracy is a single
major.
Is that all?
So we will think about better
methods, so and also the
question is that we generally
end up with a training data set
and then from the training
dataset, how can we get estimate
the accuracy that is better than
simply calculating the error
correct and wrong tuples?
So is there a way so there are
some methods of how to improve
the it's timation of accuracy
and then finally we look at some
of the Roc curves that we see
how they work.
So so we create for classifier
what is known as a confusion
matrix.
Confusion matrix.
Is that suppose there are two
classes, so we call one as C1
and other as a not C1.
So this is we can call this as a
positive and negative or
whatever we take it.
So what we do is that we plot a
cross tabulation.
Suppose that from the training
data set, we already know the
actual class, so this is the
actual class.
And these are predicted classes.
So this we referred as true
positives.
So this we call it as a false
negative because it is predicted
as a negative, but it is false.
This is false positive.
This is predicted as positive,
but it is false.
This is predicted as negative,
but it is true and it is true.
It is true negative.
So we use that to compute the
accuracy is accuracy is true
positive +2 negatives divided by
the total test data, right?
Uh, so we can compute the
accuracy.
And so can you go back to back
that slide once later?
Yes.
Sir, what does it mean that true
positive, false positive, false
Yes.
negative, true negative?
That is just these are the
numbers that you can get because
you have the training data that
is available.
So you know the actual class and
you have a classifier, so you
can also predict the class.
OK.
So in this case, what is the
accuracy?
Suppose that these are two
classes.
Whether the person is going to
buy a gadget or not, and we have
the actual classes that we know
there are 10,000 tuples so so
the accuracy is this is a
correct data.
This is the correct thing.
This is correct prediction, but
these two are erroneous
predictions.
So what is the accuracy?
So we are getting is 6954 plus
2/5 eight 8 / 10,000.
So that comes out to this
virtually .95 then this is.
12 You subtract from S4 to
right.
So this is the accuracy.
This is the way to measure the
accuracy, but but then we will
go with the error rate is 1
minus accuracy.
So this is one, but we can have
other metrics that are useful.
Particularly, we have a data
where there is a one class is
very rare.
So for example, we are talking
about a rare disease or a credit
card fraud because credit card
companies, they receive millions
of transactions.
Most of them are right.
Most of them are honest because
you know that you may be having
a credit card.
You may have had some example of
some fraud happening on your
credit card, but then you may
have used credit card thousands
of times already.
So one time it happens, so you
may remember it for a very, very
long time.
So.
So the point is that the fraud
is wrong.
A fraud is rare, but then still
the credit card company needs to
have a model to predict the
fraud, right?
So that they can still reduce
the frauds from hack occurring.
So this such when we try to
build the classifiers with such
data, we say that we have a
class imbalance problems.
So instead of going for a simple
accuracy, we go for two other
measures.
One is sensitivity and other is
specificity.
So sensitivity is talking about
the true positive recognition
and specificity is talking about
true negative recognition.
And we also have a other metrics
such as precision but incision
is telling that among the how
many of the tuples, uh.
So among the what suppose that
you predicted you build a
classifier and then asked it to
make prediction.
It predicted that eighty of them
are positive but out of them
actually only 60 are positive,
so remaining are false
positives, so the negative ones
we got reported as a positives.
So in that case we my we
calculate what is known as a
precision, which is a which is
suppose that we build, we
construct the table, so which
is.
So true positives are 60 then
false positives are 20, then
false negatives are 40.
Then this let us see.
So we are computing the
precision which is equal to.
In this case, in this case .75
be constricting the recall in
this case, which is .6, and we
use an F metric, F major or F
score, which is a combination or
a harmonic mean of these two.
So this can be one way in which
we can evaluate a classifier.
So I think, uh, I have few more
things to cover.
But you got me method of
evaluating the classifier so so
we will stop here is that let me
take if there are any questions.
Uh, so, so we we have seen this
measure.
So we will look at little more
about evaluating the classifier
further.
Sure, sure.
Yes.
Maybe in next class, right?
No.
What is the question?
No, not not.
Not a question I'm saying we'll
take the next this in the next
class.
OK.
OK, fine.
OK. Yeah.
Yeah.
No, no.
That's what we are overrunning
the time.
So I'm.
I'm just there is something
which will take again some more
time, so I'm just so we'll do
that next class is the last
class before exam.
So we will do this and we will
also review the other all the
topics we discussed till now and
and OK, next class is likely
that we may have because the
your faculty of the algorithms
Right.
class, did he inform you because
he has some next week some
commitment.
So he wants me to take the
morning slot.
He will be able to, he informed
you.
Yes, Sir.
Yes. Yeah.
Yeah, you wanted to swap.
He said.
Yes, Sir.
Yeah.
OK, OK.
So that may that is a that is
going to happen.
So we'll meet at a different
time, OK.
So what kind of questions we can
expect out of these classifiers,
and I'm going to will it be?
You may be given some data in
the US to build a classifier
right?
That's a simplest thing.
Is it not expectation?
But there can be other variants
kind.
OK.
Can you go to the presentation?
Presentation.
Yes, yes, I'm going there.
No, just give me one minute.
The P.
Yes, yes, I'm going there.
Yeah.
Tell me.
Loading for me.
Yeah, two slides back.
Yeah, two slides back is this
one.
I think slide #36.
On this one.
OK, 36 OK.
Yeah, yeah, alright, good.
Yeah.
Here you had put in the numbers.
Yeah, this how did you?
Choose a 6954 and 2588 and you
said like 46 and 412.
We can ignore.
I didn't get this part.
See.
See what we are saying is that
the the Whoever is selling the
product has got the data with.
Offer they have actually got to
10,000 test records with the
where the customers if they know
who bought and who did not buy,
then you build a model.
And So what you know is that
707,000 people actually bought
the computer, and 3000 people
did not buy it.
But your model is predicting
that out of them only 6954.
OK.
It could correctly predict 46.
It made the mistake.
Uh, so 46 cannot be the answer,
right?
Because there is a huge.
You know 46 is an incorrect
prediction from your model
In oh.
because the model is not 100%
accurate because we will never
OK.
get 100% accurate models.
Unlikely to get one, so that is
what it happened.
OK.
And then even with the wrong
side 3000 among 3000, it could
get 2588 correct, but 412 it
predicted saying that these
people will buy computer or by
the product.
OK.
OK, so so that is, yeah, tell
me.
Yeah.
So so if if you go 11 slide
back.
Hmm.
You had that false positive and.
Yes.
So this is the same thing.
So this is a true positive 6954
is true positive and 46646 is
false positive and so on.
He has a true so.
So we picked the true positives
and true negatives here, right?
Yeah, yeah, true positives, true
negatives.
They represent the accuracy.
Yeah, right.
Other things or representing the
errors.
Accuracy.
OK.
And and the accuracy formula is
that you showed in the next
page, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, right.
Same thing, yeah.
And then the next page.
Yeah, this is the one right.
True positive plus true negative
by all accuracy.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, true
positive plus two negative
divided by all.
OK.
Yeah, so this is what is
calculated there.
Fine, get it. Thanks.
Yes, alright.
OK, so so now if there if there
are no questions, we'll close
the session here.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you, Sir.
I.
Guess.
And there's a.
Thank you.